اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم قصف جوي ومدفعي اسرائيلي مكثف على
مواقع مختلفه في قطاع غزه وشهداء وجرحى في
غارات على رفح وخانيونس جنوبا وجباليا
شمالا ووزاره الصحه في غزه تقول ان اكثر
من 390 شهيدا سقطوا خلال يومين ومسؤوله
امميه تحذر من ان اسرائيل تسعى الى تهجير
اغلبيه اهالي قطاع غزه
جيش الاحتلال يعلن مقتل ضابط وجندي واصابه
23 جنديا خلال يوم في معارك غزه وبعد
الاعلان عن انسحاب كتيبه من لواء جولان من
القطاع اثر تكبده خسائر كبيره جيش
الاحتلال يقول ان خمسه الويه من قواته
تخوض المعارك في خانيونس وكتائب القسام
تعلن استهداف مجموعه من الجنود
الاسرائيليين وثلاث دبابات وتقول انها
دمرت اكثر من 700
اليه اسرائيليه منذ بدء العمليات
البريه وسط انتقادات داخليه وخلافات في
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي نتنياهو يشدد على
ان اسرائيل لن توقف الحرب قبل القضاء على
حماس واستعاده المختطفين وكتائب القسام
تبث صورا لثلاثه اسرى قالت انهم قتلوا
بسلاح جيش الاحتلال وابو عبيده يشدد على
ان الوسيله الوحيده للافراج عن الاسرى
احياء هي و العدوان على
غزه اصابه فلسطيني برصاص قوات الاحتلال
غرب جنين بذري محاوله تنفيذه عمليه دهس
وجرح 14 اخرين في مواجهات مع جيش الاحتلال
في مختلف مدن الضفه الغربيه ونادي الاسير
الفلسطيني يعلن ارتفاع عدد المعتقلين في
سجون الاحتلال حتى نهايه الشهر الماضي الى
اكثر من 8 الاف الى
اللقاء
l